uno de los grandes retos que enfrentará
el nuevo gobierno es dar un giro a la
economía del país y especialmente
encontrar una solución para la creación
de empleo entre los jóvenes a 26 años en
lo cual tiene una maestría en diseño y
arte gráfico desde hace tres años
trabaja como un mototaxi un trabajo
prohibido en el país
cuando terminas la escuela no tienes
trabajo lo que intento decir es que si
el gobierno puede hacer algo al respecto
estaría bien
sin ver su futuro y futuro trabajo en lo
cual me espera la legalización de los
mototaxis
tal vez el gobierno podría ayudarnos
legalizando a nuestro trabajo asegúrate
de que todos tengan su licencia su
seguro para trabajar en resumen todo en
orden
que otros colegas de el usualmente los
listas y no esperan nada del gobierno
y no
lo que hacemos es sobrevivir porque si
no tienes nada nadie te va a dar nada
áfrica es serio en esto es un lugar
donde tenemos un montón de gobiernos que
vienen y dicen parezca de eso no cumplen
sus promesas sólo unos pocos lo hacen
vengan a el número de pobres apela a
kiss momento en el último decenio en
prometió una cuarta parte de la
población sigue viviendo por debajo del
umbral de pobreza en el futuro el
gobierno debe embestir en la
distribución de la riqueza
[Música]